un drapeau de la fierté couvert
d'ecchymoses
en cette journée de lutte contre
l'homophobie et la transphobie la
fondation émergence veut jeter un
éclairage sur les violences subies par
les membres de la communauté lgbt qu
chaque couleurs de l'arc en ciel est en
fait la couleur d'un visage tuméfié
derrière la fierté il ya tout un univers
de violence malheureusement qu'il faut
dénoncer et qu'il faut prendre acte plus
on avance au niveau des droits plus on
s'affirme et malheureusement il peut ça
peut susciter des réactions négatives
des réactions négatives qui mène souvent
à la violence verbale et physique même
au canada
on va le donner des coups de pied au
visage et je suis réveillé de tous ceux
à l'hôpital à l'été 2010 9 marc antoine
lynch boisvert et son conjoint ont été
rué de coups lors d'une attaque
caractère homophobe dans charlevoix à
son réveil à l'hôpital
si la colère qui l'habite je te frustre
et puis comme je peux pas croire que ça
m'arrive je veux pas croire que encore
aujourd'hui l'on en 2010 à l'époque on
était encore à près de se battre est
littéralement le cas de marc antoine est
loin d'être isolé selon les plus
récentes données de statistique canada
le nombre de crimes haineux basée sur
l'orientation sexuelle a explosé dans
les dernières années passant de 155 cas
rapportés policiers en 2014 à 263 en
2019 à l'étranger l'homosexualité est
encore considérée comme un crime est
puni dans 69 pays dont le bangladesh la
république dominicaine et le cameroun
selon l'observatoire des inégalités p67
transsexuels camerounaise a écopé de
cinq ans de prison la semaine dernière
pour tentative d'une sexualité ça veut
dire que toi si tu es homosexuel connu
présumés comme tel mais soupçonnait même
comme tels que ne mérite pas d'avoir ta
place dans la société
le cameroun ne posent pas la peine
capitale mais non 11 pays une personne
reconnue coupable d'avoir eu des
relations homosexuelles est passible de
la peine de mort ici jérôme bergeron
radio canada montréal